tenemos fx es igual a 2x raíz de 54 y
gtx es igual a x al cuadrado más 2x raíz
de 5 menos uno lo que nos piden es
determinar g - efe de x y lo único que
tenemos que recordar es que esta función
la función g - efe es la función que se
obtiene de restar g con efe de restar
cada una de las de estas definiciones es
decir la nueva función gm efe y evaluada
en el punto x es igual a gd x menos f de
x y sabiendo esto ya podemos sustituir
gx y fx para continuar desarrollando
déjame hacer esto entonces mira aquí
tenemos fx en color verde que es este
término que acá tenemos gdx en color
morado lo voy a poner que es este de acá
y por lo tanto nos quedaría x al
cuadrado lo voy a poner así x al
cuadrado más 2 x raíz de cinco menos uno
y a eso tenemos que restar fx y fx es 2x
2x raíz de 5 raíz de 5 menos 4 muy bien
vamos a realizar esta operación el
primer paréntesis lo podemos quitar sin
problemas nos quedaría x cuadrada más 2x
raíz de 5 menos uno pero como aquí
estamos restando este signo menos lo
debemos distribuir en este paréntesis es
como si aquí fuera un -1 y este menos
uno lo distribuyera mos sobre cada uno
de estos términos bueno que nos quedaría
entonces menos 1 x 2 x raíz de 5 es
menos 2x raíz de 5 y menos uno por menos
4 menos por menos es más nos queda más 4
muy bien ya nada más tenemos que
simplificar aquí tenemos una x cuadrada
que es el único término con exponente
igualados
entonces nos quedaría igual a x al
cuadrado vamos con los términos lineales
vamos con la
en color naranja aquí tenemos dos por x
por raíz de 5 entonces este es un
término lineal pero observa aquí está su
negativo menos 2 x por raíz de 5
entonces al sumar este con este se
cancela en verdad si a 2x raíz de 5 le
restamos 2x raíz de 5 eso claramente
edad 0 entonces no hay términos lineales
bueno se cancelaron y finalmente los
últimos términos que nos quedan son este
menos 1 y este 4 los términos constantes
y 4 menos uno es igual a tres
entonces nos queda x cuadrada x cuadrada
más 3 muy bien entonces tenemos que g
- efe de x es igual a x cuadrada más 3 y
lo más importante es recordar que la
función gm
efe es la función dada por restar las
definiciones de g y la de f